it's a tough sell because it's it goes
beyond there seems to be an maybe it's
cross control maybe there's something
genetic I don't know but you're right
there seems to be a resistance in young
males to reading so maybe it's a
question of finding the right book maybe
the right way to pass on the word maybe
they'd like were you know oral words
maybe they're more susceptible to plays
maybe I'm not sure it's a question of
Education it's a question of having
their elders so older males read I've
noticed that in reading males young
males read old males read it's the
middle ones and of course the problem is
that we are dominated by the middle ones
we're dominated by middle middle aged
men historically they're the ones who
have been the rulers and there have been
they're the ones who had the most power
so we somehow seem to miss them I'm not
sure I think it's a question of
education is question setting by
examples question finding the right
books I'm not sure
I think it's a great idea I have no fear
of it I think it'll save some trees and
there's infinite pot it has infinite
possibilities so to have an electronic
book where if you don't know a word you
tap on it and it's defined for you to
have a device where you know but you
could upend encyclopedia so if you're if
you're reading a novel set in Paraguay
and you're curious about Paraguay you
can tap and get a map of Paraguay and to
have a book that perhaps at one point
you know you're reading an is novel why
not have Indian music in the background
to have a book that can then start
reading to you you know it's a great
idea it's particularly suited for stuff
that's ephemeral newspaper is ephemeral
fiction and if you really like a work if
you're reading great poetry then you
have it on your kindle but also you get
it as a book so i think they can be
complementary you know every new
technology has its limitations has its
dangers the danger of the e-book of
courses that will be kidnapped by
corporations whether it's apple or Sony
or whatever because it is a proprietary
propyne ebooks right now our proprietary
technology whereas books books aren't
paper books are not anyone can make a
book so hopefully at one point will be a
generic products like the phone is like
an actual physical phone is anyone can
make a phone now any number of companies
but as an idea I think it's wonderful it
still needs work but I've no I have no
fear of them i don't have one myself but
i have no problems with them
you